Here's a very effective way to capture
high R setups with very little to no
effort and it's called the opening range
breakout strategy or the initial
balance, right? And so, at the end of
the day, all this really is is in the
first 15 to 60 minutes of major
sessions, dailies, weekly, monthly
opens, institutions reveal their intent.
Volume spikes, liquidity shifts, and
price action set the opening range.
Paired with that with the VWAP or the
ORB strategy helps us follow
institutional flows with structure and
precision, okay?
So, the opening range is defined as the
high and the low of the first 15 minutes
or 60 minutes of the regular trading
session and for this session today,
we're going to look at the daily open,
okay? So, really when we get into it,
the very first thing that you always
want to do is understand the higher time
frame range that you're trading in,
okay? And that is just using the fixed
range volume profile tool. Now, for this
example, we're going to look at a short
that was taken about 2 days ago, um if
not yesterday. So, this is very, very
constructive and easy to do and all
we're going to do is identify where was
the open, right? So, the open that
occurred and let's go ahead and look at
our levels. So, this is a daily, right?
At the time, this looks like this
because it is a daily
open, okay? So, this is a daily open,
but for this example, it's already
became a daily level, right? So, how
this looks is we're going to look at,
okay, it is 7:00 p.m. on CST my time
and I'm going to go down to lower time
frames, preferably the 30 minute or the
15 minute. And we have this nice kind of
value built up. So, at this moment,
you're kind of tracking the overall
volume in this value, right? So, you
kind of understand, all right, there's
already a value built up in here, the
daily just opened. Where do we have our
opening range? Well, daily just opened,
we had a good spike up and all of a
sudden, there's a little bit of a volume
spike in here, right? So, at this moment
in time, you're understanding where
you're at in confluence with the value
area high. So, this is AMT framework and
then we're doing what? Our nice trusty
friend, the 618 golden pocket backtest
and we're looking at, are we
backtesting, right? Cuz this is also, as
I said, in a higher time frame context,
we are outside the value area range and
we are kind of placing ourselves in a
lower high structure, so a bit of a
pullback could be expected while we're
still kind of coming up into higher low,
higher high structure. Now, the reason
that is important is because you want to
understand where the higher timeframe
value sits, and if we're likely to come
back down to it as we have already done.
So, you already have kind of somewhat of
a short-term local bias, and so you're
looking for a what? A lower high
structure, so local like local timeframe
lower high, lower lows, lower highs,
lower lows, and so on and so on, which
we've gotten. So, we got our good friend
the 618 backtest, we got our great
friend the anchored VWAP from the swing
highs, okay? Now, when we get into this
on a very lower timeframe, I really only
trade daily opens and New York open. So,
why? Because the orb strategy or the
initial uh balance is very, very easy to
trade. So, you get your nice daily open,
you come up to what? The value area high
of this local range, you come up and
flip it to support, support, support
tested. At this moment in time, you're
kind of assessing order flow,
um and you're assessing volume, right?
So, at this moment in time, you start to
continue to pull the fixed range volume
profile in your favor and understand
where volume's at. So, when you get to
this point, you're going to look at this
and say, "Oh, okay. Well, we have kind
of started to lose the value area high,
we've rejected the 72, we've lost the
66, and we've lost the 618. We're coming
back down to the daily open."
Now, with that being said,
why does the opening range breakout
matter? Well, when you have an initial
range like this, you have your kind of
range highs of your first 15 minutes to
the 60 minutes. For this, this is about
um this is about 60 minutes, two an
hour, right? 60 minutes to two hours.
And then you have your local range low.
So, you kind of have this range where
you could continue to kind of do this,
and let's say for this example, right?
If we broke up like this, you would have
what? A long trade to look at from a
swing perspective up to the highs,
right? In this case, we're looking for
shorts with the bias coming back down to
the value area low of that higher
timeframe. So, it's a very simple setup
when you look at this and you say,
"Well, you know what? I'm going to look
and play the breakdown the loss of the
daily open." And I'm either going to do
two one or two things. I'm going to keep
my validation above the swing highs and
give it some room to breathe, or for
those of you who like to have better um
tighter risk management, um you can have
a closer structure like this. Now,
for this example, we've already broken
down through this mini range here,
come down and we have pushed through the
daily open with um a lot of size, okay?
So, now we've done two things, right?
We've SFPd the value area high, we've
back tested, and we've placed a lower
high potential. We've lost the daily
open, and the next major value is the
point of control. So, even on a scalp
perspective, you can scalp this really
really easily and capture, you know, 33
basis points on something like this.
Now, for someone like me who's swing
trading, I want to look at fading this
back to the larger value, okay? Which
again is this overall larger range
perspective, okay? And that's back to
where we are now. So, the opening range
is very very simple. You look for
around the daily open
price to kind of dance around, and in
this case it's a short setup inside this
value. So, without even looking at the
daily open, the number one thing that
you would do is look for an SFP of the
value area high, take a setup when we
have acceptance back into it, and play
it. All we're doing is factoring the
daily open in because we have a very
favorable daily open, and then the swing
high AVWAP coming in nicely, and you can
see in real time when we zoom into this
how it's very very effectively lost as
support, right? Cuz it was support here
at this moment. We came up up to the
value area high, and then now we've lost
as support. We come down, we tap the
point of control, and what do we do now?
Well, we come back up, we test it as
resistance.
We also have um let's see if this is a
618 back test at that time. So, we did
have another 618 back test at this time
at this point. So, you have nice
confluence there, dynamic resistance
band with the 618 retracement.
Kind of in the middle of value, so I
wouldn't really You could always do
something like this and take a setup and
then have your entry confirmation for
someone who's more patient.
But at the end of the day, you then kind
of start to look at where this trend
goes. And if you're swinging, well, if
you have this value built out, you know
that price is kind of doing what? A
lower low, lower high,
lower low, lower high, and so on and so
on. And you can see very effectively how
this swing high AV up acts as
resistance, right? We kind of came up in
through this, tried to flip the value
area low as support, did a good job of
that, but then at the same time, the
point of control of this value is
flipped as
resistance.
And then what did we do? We flipped to
resistance. We had one more attempt back
up, almost flipped it back to the
support, but again, sellers are in
control, resistance, resistance, and at
the end of the day, you can It's clearly
see the sellers are definitely in
control because you're having lower
high, lower high, lower high, lower
high, lower high. So, you have very nice
resistance at confirmation with AMT, and
then you basically are taking your trade
off the loss of the daily open. In this
case, it's very favorable, and now you
get to relax and hang out in your setup,
right? And this is a real setup that was
taken, nothing crazy.
Again, just kind of the initial balance,
and we'll go ahead and talk through a
long setup that was taken last week. But
for example, this is just the short
setup for initial balance. And then we
play this back down to value area low.
And with that being said, you have your
value area at the hourly acting now as a
um
Uh this is the right pull right here,
right? Acting as a TP1, right? And you
look to trail this down lower and lower
through major value. If this is accepted
here, well, now you have a very
favorable swing trade. You look for
this, and you play it down to next
value, and next value, and then that's
how you kind of start to swing based on
an opening range breakout. So, we're
taking a very lower time frame trade
setup with a higher time frame swing
mindset. Now, let's go ahead and look at
something, uh, in terms of
what we can do for a long setup, right?
And we'll do BTC because it's very easy.
BTC loves the opening range breakout and
it's very, very well for something like
this. So, let's go and look at the in
the same range just at a earlier
timeframe.
This is the daily perspective, okay? So,
here's a daily open that happened.
And then when we zoom in, we can clearly
see that we have an opening range, so to
speak. And what do we do? We do the
first thing where we take our fixed
range volume profile and we assess where
the overall profile is, right? Now, this
is a bit of a skewed profile. This isn't
overlapping, but in my opinion, this is
still valid to pull and you kind of
consider to play this out and see where
the value lives, right? So, at this
time, you have your daily open.
You have another thing, right? Your
higher timeframe perspective. So, our
higher timeframe perspective comes into
play when we zoom back out to the
hourly. We can clearly see that we have
another anchored view up with the swing
low and that is acting as really great
support once, twice, and then we were
looking for that a third time, okay? And
that's very simple because you go back
to the daily open. You say that you're
closing and opening the daily almost
basically below that swing low a view up
so there's potential for an SFP pattern
as we've seen, reclaim, and then have a
major run up. So, when we do something
like this, we do assess the first 50 to
60, um, you know, the 60 to 120, you
know, minutes of the opening range. You
know, there's no real timeframe. I like
to say the first 60 minutes.
Realistically, often it can be an hour
to 3 hours, uh, but you can clearly see,
especially in here, you have your daily
open right here. You have your bit of
your range low.
And then you have your range high, okay?
It's very simple, something like this.
And now you kind of see how price kind
of bounces through something like this.
And that's when you take your opening
range breakout strategy. And that's
paired with the local value area, the
swing low, and any other sort of, you
know, Fibonaccis you can pull, anything
that's going to help you in terms of
where is the 61866,
um, is there an MPOC here, is there a
weekly level? You stack on that
confluence, right? But at the end of the
day, very simple, you continue to pull
this level, right? As price moves out.
And at the end of the day, if if CBD
looks good, if Delta looks good, then
you take your long setup, right?
And you place your stops either below
this low or this low here. And this was,
you know, again, another example of a
range trade breakout. So, you're
basically targeting from, right, the
point of control. This is a real trade
taken here. You can clearly see the
entry price, the entry level, and then
where we've kind of traded this up to,
right? So, it's really simple. Local AMT
framework inside of a higher time frame
AMT framework, looking at the opening
range breakout strategy, understanding
local market structure, taking a trade
based off a good entry trigger on terms
of order flow footprint, and then
looking to trade this back up above the
overall point of control, back up to
value area high, right? So, on a higher
time frame,
you can clearly see, you know, we've
we've reclaimed the point of control on
higher time frames. We take the setup.
Anchor VWAP is holding very nicely. And
then we look for another move back up to
the upside of the value area high,
right? And that's exactly what you do
over and over and over again. I
encourage you to go and backtest this at
any major, you know, daily open,
constructive daily open, anything like
that, right? It's going to be very
favorable. I'm pretty sure even when we
look at a another long setup, this is
also applies to a long setup that I had
taken back at the 58K zone. So, when we
look at the 58K zone, let me look at my
folder structure here and grab this for
you. So, we have the I might have
actually deleted my
my swing setup. Well, we'll go ahead and
close it here and we can always come
back to this at a different time and
place, YouTube. But you guys get the
overall idea of how you can kind of
structure this from a short perspective
opening range, how you can structure
this from a long perspective opening
range or initial balance, right? Your
daily open and your New York opens are
going to be your most favorable entry
zones, okay? And at this point in time,
as we speak, you know, you have two
favorable swing setups, right? You have
this one running in in and you're
looking to trade this up higher. and
then you have a short set up that you're
taking this lower and looking to trade
this. Obviously, if we break that back
down into this major value, we trade
this back down below. Um it's kind of
the same thing that we just did on ETH
earlier today, too, right? We had a
fresh daily open in this zone.
A bit of a different balance, if you
will, right? Kind of a local balance in
this range. We then have a daily open.
We understand that the market structure
is trending in a lower high structure.
We're having good 618 back test. We have
that nice anchored VWAP from our swing
highs coming down as resistance, and
then we have our daily open, right? And
for this example, this is not an opening
range breakout strategy, so to speak,
because the opening range in this
context is somewhat similar in this
range, right? And we kind of broke down.
So, you could have taken an aggressive
long there or short, and then traded
this down. For me, I wanted to see a bit
more patience on Ethereum, especially
because Ethereum can be more volatile
than BTC, so it may take a little bit of
time. But ultimately, what I'm saying is
I have the daily open in terms of this
context. I understand that we're trading
below the daily open. It's likely that
once we lose the daily open, we
oftentimes get another back test to the
daily open, and I'll look for a setup
right there.
In this instance, we have confirmation
that we have a 618 back test, right?
From this swing, this lower high to this
lower low. We have the VWAP, we didn't
even make it to the VWAP, and then we
lose our kind of
um
point of control area. So, you you know,
for me personally, I kind of took a more
of aggressive approach here. Stops above
the last lower high because it's
trending nicely. We have a good support,
we have a good resistance right here,
and then we look to trade that lower.
For somebody who's kind of camping this
more, you could definitely have a more
aggressive invalidation set up here or
here, and then you look to trade that
back to what? The value area low, and
then our good friend, right? The overall
higher time frame value area. So, back
to this value area low would be the
target, right? And it's the same thing
for weekly opens on here. So, if we look
at Ethereum, we understand, well,
where's the weekly open in this context?
Well, it could be a very valuable.
Sometimes it can be hard as well for
weekly opens because you have a lot of
chop in this instance, right?
So, if we go back to the weekly open on
BTC, we are actually back at the weekly
open right now.
Now, you can clearly do this in terms of
being more patient and understanding,
well, where is the weekly open, right?
If you take a short at the loss of the
weekly open level, it's often times that
we come back to the weekly open. Well,
we're kind of at the value area high, so
you are in a bit of a pickle, right? You
do want to look for shorts at this
example, but sometimes you want to be
patient. So, it's really more effective
on the daily opens than it is the
weekly's cuz the weekly's take a little
bit more time, right? But, they always
act as good support and resistance
later, right? So, at this moment in
time, if you're looking at the weekly
open as a great area for longs, right?
Then you can say, you know what, I'm
interested in something like this. And
you can say, well, you know what, I'm
going to look at what confluence I have
there. And right now, we have a few
places of confluence that we can look
at, right? So, when we kind of pull this
together,
again, this is kind of going off the
whim here, guys, but just bear with me.
And we kind of look at the confluence
that we have in this zone. There's two
things that you can do. One, obviously,
look at the Let's go back to the USDT
pair cuz that's where I have this going.
Go to the NPOCs. We have a naked point
of control. We then have also a
Fibonacci retracement from the swing low
to the swing high. You could also look
at where is the latest anchored VWAP?
Well, it might be coming from this major
pivot here. So, if we have resistance
acting as resistance right now in this
this zone, for me personally, I'm kind
of interested in a long right here, but
at the end of the day, the weekly open
can be um a good place to look for a
long down here. Otherwise, you look for
something like this, the value area high
as a reclaim of this 24-week
uh actually, this is a 7-week value area
high, something like this, and then you
have your entry trigger, and then you
wait for, you know, your weekly open as
support. So, the daily opens, the weekly
opens can be really, really effective,
right? The more uh higher time frame it
is, the more weight it carries. For
example, the monthly open. The monthly
open is a very important one to look at,
especially in terms of larger swings,
because what you do have down here,
right?
Is your monthly open. You have initial
monthly open balance. What did we do?
Well, we swept the lows on the monthly
open balance. We came back, reclaimed it
as support, and then we ran up, right?
And that's a very simple 618 back test
off the lows. And then you look and you
take that set up all day, every day,
because that is exactly what we do for
swing trades. And we look to swing that
up higher, right? So, at the end of the
day, you have a good swing trade off
your monthly. You look for the dailies
and the weekly opens and then your New
York opens. So, this is the opening
range breakout strategy. Very effective,
very simple.
And I hope you guys enjoy. Cheers.